alors
quoi salut les sportifs bonne année
merci c'est les résolutions là non pas
spécialement c'est quoi vos résolutions
là pour cette année je l'ai pas pris
spécialement ah ouais non du tout non
plus non plus bonne année on voulait
savoir est-ce que vous avez des bonnes
résolutions oh bah oui toujours moi ah
oui Mo je suis un battant moi ça rigole
pas avec moi vous avez des des
résolutions là pour cette année porter
le M costume que vous ok très bon choix
très bon choix et vous moi un peu de
régime perdre un kil ou de mais avec le
sourire sans contrainte trop difficile
ok pas de sport quoi du sport quand même
si si je vais travailler et voilà se
mettre à fumer peut-être pour arrêter
non ben non c'est compliqué sinon moi
les résolutions c'est toujours d'être en
forme faire du sport aimer les autres
voilà et puis un petit peu d'argent
quand même donc pas comme l'année
dernière quoi euh peut-être un peu mieux
voilà toujours mieux vous faites quoi là
en fait faites des tours la calistthénie
ouais ça s'appelle comment la
calistthénie c'est ça ouais c'est ça
c'est quoi la définition de la
calistthénie c'est des points de corp
sur les sur les barres sur tous
lesexercices quoi comme sport ben muscu
jogging vélo
et le calistenie non ouais mais en
amateur hein parce que c'est pas comme
les youtubeurs qui sont déjà
surdévloppés quoi ouais je connais ouais
mais tout le monde connais calal c'est
de la muscu à haut poids de corps ouais
et puis avec des figures des des efforts
continu c'est très puissant vous faites
de la calisténie peut-être euh non non
vous savez ce que c'est non moi non plus
je savais pas de 3 K c'est rien du tout
à perdre ouais c'est vrai mais moi c'est
les pâtisseries regardez on
va on est
grillé c'est pour
demain Gau
r en train de regarder des gars qui font
la
Calie j'ai perdu 1 kil il y a un truc
simple à faire pour là mes résolutions
de sportifs de l'année là apprend à
faire des tractions vous pouvez faire un
concours tous les deux là pour voir tous
les trois tous les trois tous les trois
ok c'est moi qui donne le départ ça va
ok euh celui qui en fait le plus 3 2 1
c'est parti ah ouais balaise tu tiens
pas le coup
flcher ah ouais ça rigole pas les deux
gars
là solide merci pour cette démonstration
tuétais pas terrible toi si si pas bon
ben merci
ouais faut être deux ou faut pas être
deux alors c'est pas mal ça ça c'est
vraiment pas mal j'ai l'impression que
ma jambe gauche est plus grande que la
droite et toi c'est quoi ta résolution
moi mes résolutions c'est de continuer à
vivre jusqu'au prochaine
résolution tu fatiguant en fait un peu
moi j'arrête ouais Mo aussi allez bonne
année je sais pas si ça se fait comme
ça
en gros j'aimerais faire du sport et que
mon collègue me filme pendant que je
fais du sport AC cette tenue si j'enlève
la veste ou je comprends tu peux pas fa
de sport comme ça pas faire SP ça je
suis sûr
j'arrive c'estci résolution bonjour
bonjour on cherche des bonnes
résolutions là mais des très très bonnes
résolutions c'est le pays des bonnes
résolutions ici non surtout qu'on a que
ça c'est quoi vos bonnes résolution vous
pas que de la bonne dégustation ok voilà
tout simplement très bien des moments de
partage et de plaisir super voilà est-ce
qu'on pourrait peut-être goûter une
bonne résolution de partager le plaisir
ah qu'est-ce que vous aimez plutôt
qu'est-ce qu'on aime pour la bonne année
202 la bonne résolution normalement on
devrait être àop pétillante hein on a
bonjour ah on peut pas goûter ah al
plutôt RH ou plutôt whisky euh pour
fêter une bonne année 2024 qu'est-ce
qu'on boit du R tiens allez allez un
petit r alors c'est vraiment bien
parti qu viens de la et le mec il un
r on fait des tours ouais on marche
voyage de ver du coup
un tout petit alors je suis dans les
bonnes résolution aussi donc oui oui
alors comment on déguste une bonne
résolution
ah et vous comment buvez-vous du du
R en fait c'est un peu la même la même
procédée que le vin ouais donc on a le
le visuel le nez et on termine par la
bouche la différence c'est que là on est
sur un produit à 40°gr à contrar du de
du vin on est à 12 13 degr maximum merci
beaucoup mais avec grand PL bonne
résolution bonne année bonne
santé de la part de toute l'équipe alor
quadb nous vous souhaitons une bonne
année sachez que même s'il fait moche il
fait toujours beau quelque
[Musique]
part